and now for tonight's angle the Trump
administration takes the caravan to
court well no doubt you've heard about
the caravan of illegal immigrants moving
north through Mexico well according to
the New York Times over a hundred have
already made it to the US border the
caravan started out with more than a
thousand people and is now down to about
500 or so now some of these migrants
have told reporters that they plan to
find ways to get across the US border
now most of them are from Honduras so
many are expected to apply for asylum
supposedly to escape violence at home
well anticipating that the Trump
administration is sending additional ice
attorneys Justice Department judges and
also prosecutors to make sure the
caravan asylum cases will be quote
adjudicated promptly but we've also
learned this is curious that American
attorneys have travelled southward to
meet with migrants to instruct them on
their rights to apply for asylum here in
the United States we did some digging
and according to reports two of these
lawyers are Allegra love of Santa Fe
dreamers project and Murray Vincent who
also works for a small 501c3
organization Vincent has said that many
of the migrants are strong candidates
for asylum because they're fleeing
political persecution or violent gangs
or threats over their gender or sexual
orientation but for asylum eligibility
according to section 1208 of the title 8
code of federal regulation the media
have been claiming that these are
political refugees escaping violence and
yes persecution it's really more of
anything a symbolic kind of PR move by
the migrants who want to talk about and
want to bring
to the lack of rule of law and the human
rights violations that occur in Central
America every time the president gets at
a political jam any time he's feeling
threatened politically he goes back to a
few of the same things beating up on
immigrants and Mexicans are criminals
the picture of President Trump paints is
hordes of immigrants many of them
criminals poised to storm the border but
the caravan CNN found is a very
different scenario we will take you live
to meet the families many women and
children waiting for their next move
well their next move is to crash into
our country well the problem of the
attorneys helping the members of the
caravan could be the US law the Code
section 1213 24 excuse me of title 8
which makes it an offence for any person
who encourages or induces an alien to
come to enter or reside in the United
States knowing or in reckless disregard
of the fact that such coming to entry or
residence is or will be in violation of
law so the question is when this
advocacy for illegals end up crossing
the line to committing a 1324 offense
interesting legal question well because
of the attorney-client privilege this
could be tough to determine but if these
attorneys are holding what is being
described as these large group seminars
and demonstrate intent to skirt the laws
or to help the migrants skirt the laws
well they could be in jeopardy at least
technically here's the other problem for
these lawyers most of the people in this
Caravan as I said are from Honduras well
a poll conducted by a Jesuit research
group found a whopping 83% of Hondurans
who are considering migrating to the
United States were motivated by purely
economic reasons in other words they
simply wanted to move to a wealthier
country with better economic
opportunities only 11 percent said they
wanted to leave due to violence and
insecurity so given that poll
immigration judges
would be really skeptical about these
asylum claims and if these claims a lot
of them are bogus as I assume most of
them are what does that say about the
attorneys themselves Michael Cohen
Trump's personal attorney remember he
was called a fixer well what would you
call members of the American Bar who
arguably connive with their clients to
thwart or get around US immigration law
or at least game it and how do many of
these migrants know exactly what to say
to asylum judges well it's almost like
when you when you hear this they're
almost working off of the same script
how would they all know to say the same
thing huh well the president is doing
the right thing he's heading the caravan
off at the pass this is what he tweeted
yesterday he said I've instructed the
Secretary of Homeland Security not to
let these large caravans of people into
our country and another tweet wrote
Mexico whose laws on immigration are
very tough must stop people from going
through Mexico and into the United
States we may make this a condition of
the new NAFTA agreement well the plan is
to detain any asylum seekers until their
hearings the others will be prosecuted
for illegal entry and I say good catch
and release does not work the Trump
administration said they were ending it
it must be ended now there could be no
more catch and promised you'll show up
for your asylum hearing because as we
know and we discussed this many times on
the angle the vast majority of those
asylum seekers never show up at their
hearing they just disappear into society
Trump is right to partner with Mexico to
stop the flood of immigrants pouring
through Mexico southern border tying
results to trade I mean it might be the
only thing we can do might be a really
good idea in building the wall my
goodness if you can't see that building
the wall is more necessary than ever now
you must be blind
the president should also put Honduras
on notice that this virtual invasion has
to stop son virtual it's a real invasion
even if that means things don't change
threatening to suspend foreign aid which
Honduras desperately needs it would also
help if we got our own house in order
and stop the abuse of asylum and the
process of applying and facilitating it
by American lawyers more has to be done
their so-called asylum seekers all get
their day in court but for the American
citizen security and justice always
seems delayed and that's the angle